all right joining us now with more
investigative journalists and reporter
and fox news contributor sarah carter
all right title 42 rescinding it's a cdc
order for the pandemic that allows this
country to return people to the country
of their origin and that looks like it's
going to be repealed and already
migrant caravans are forming to come to
the border maybe in larger numbers than
last year
oh much larger numbers than last year
sean they're expecting a tsunami a wave
of people coming from all over the world
i can tell you this since fiscal year so
we're looking from october the fiscal
year border patrol october 2021 until
now there's been over a million
apprehensions i was told by a senior uh
dhs official that 600 000
gotaways on top of those 1 million
apprehensions were expected this year
alone and they're expecting more than
three million people to be apprehended
by the end of this fiscal year it's
absolutely incredible and i was up there
with uh dps air patrol and i can tell
you the thing they are most concerned
about sean are the people that are
coming over the mountains where i was at
in camo people that did not want to be
captured there were narcotics we
actually
were able to fly over an area where
three huge bundles of marijuana over 300
pounds of marijuana had been left in the
canyon ridge to be picked up later then
the people disappeared they disappeared
shawn onto i-90 onto i-10
there's resources are limited and it is
a very very dangerous situation these
are not people that want to be turning
themselves into border patrol these are
people that are wearing camo they're
trying to get away they're trying to
blend into the environment they're
bringing fentanyl and other drugs and
very dangerous very dangerous situation
for both our law enforcement officials
as well as americans and those that are
being trafficked
all right sara carter thank you for that
report hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else